it's possible that a human-like
intelligent civilization has previously
existed on Earth the reason I say this
is like
it is jarring to think that we would not
if they weren't extinct we wouldn't be
able to find evidence of them after a
sufficient matter after a sufficient
amount of time of course there's like
like basically humans like if we destroy
ourselves now
the human civilization destroy ourselves
now after a sufficient amount of time we
would not be we'd find evidence of the
dinosaurs we would not find evidence of
us humans yeah that's kind of an odd
thing to think about although
I'm not sure if we have enough knowledge
about species going back for billions of
years we could we could we might be able
to eliminate that possibility but it's
an interesting question of course this
is a similar question to you know there
were lots of intelligent species about
our galaxy that have all disappeared uh
that's super sad that
um they're exactly that there may have
been much more intelligent alien
civilizations in our galaxy that are no
longer there yeah
um you actually talked about this
um that humans might destroy ourselves
yeah and how we might
preserve our knowledge yeah
and advertise that knowledge to other
advertisers the funny word to use the
art from the pr person there's no
financial gain in this
uh you know like make it like from a
tourism perspective make it interesting
can you describe how well there's a
couple things I broke it down into two
parts actually three parts one is
um
you know there's a lot of things we know
that what if what if we were what if we
ended what if our civilization collapsed
yeah I'm not talking tomorrow yeah we
could be a thousand years from now like
you know we don't really know but but
historically it would be likely at some
point time flies when you're having fun
yeah it's a good way to put it
um you know could we and then then
intelligent life evolved again on this
planet
wouldn't they want to know a lot about
us and what we knew when they wouldn't
be able to ask us questions so one very
simple thing I said how would we archive
what we know that was a very simple idea
I said you know what that wouldn't be
that hard to put a few satellites you
know going around this Nissan and upload
Wikipedia every day and
um that kind of thing uh so you know if
we end up killing ourselves well it's up
there in the next intelligence piece
we'll find it and learn something that
would be they would like that they would
appreciate that the uh so that's one
thing the next thing I said well what if
you know
how outside of our solar system
we have the seti program we're looking
for these intelligent signals from
everybody and if you do a little bit of
math which I did in the book uh and you
say well a lot of intelligent species
only live for ten thousand years before
you know technologically intelligent
species like ones are really able to do
this we're just starting to be able to
do
um well the chances are we wouldn't be
able to see any of them because they
would have all been disappeared by now
um they've lived there ten thousand
years and now they're gone and so we're
not going to find these signals being
sent from these people because
um but I said what kind of signal could
you create that would last a million
years or a billion years that someone
would say
damn it some are smart live there we
know that that would be a life-changing
event for us to figure that out well
what we're looking for today in the
study program isn't that we're looking
for very coded signals in some sense
um and so I asked myself what would be a
different type of signal one could
create
um I've always thought about this
throughout my life and in the book I
gave one one possible suggestion which
was
um uh we now detect planets going around
other other Suns uh other stars excuse
me and we do that by seeing this the the
slight dimming of the light as the
planets move in front of them that's how
we detect uh planets elsewhere in our
galaxy what if we created something like
that that just rotated around our our
around the sun and it blocked out a
little bit of the light in a particular
pattern that someone said hey that's not
a planet that is a sign that someone was
once there you can see what if it's
beating up Pi you know three point
whatever
broadly broadcast takes no continue
activation on our part this is the key
right no one has to be sitting here
running a computer and supplying it with
power it just goes on so we go it's
continues and and I argue that part of
the study program should be looking for
signals like that and to look for
signals like that you ought to figure
out what the how would we create a
signal like what would we create that
would be like that that would persist
for millions of years that would be
broadcast broadly you could see from a
distance there was unequivocal it came
from an A by an intelligent species and
so I gave that one example
um because they don't know what I know
of actually and then and then finally
right
if if our ultimately our solar system
will die at some point in time you know
how do we go beyond that and I think
it's possible if at all possible we'll
have to create intelligent machines that
travel throughout this throughout the
solar system or without the Galaxy and I
don't think that's going to be humans I
don't think it's going to be biological
organisms so these are just things to
think about you know like what's up you
know I kind of I don't want to be like
the dinosaur I don't want to just live
in like that was it we're done you know
well there is a kind of presumption that
we're going to live forever which uh I I
think it is a bit sad
to imagine that the message we send is
as you talk about is that we were once
here
instead of we are here well it could be
we are still here uh
but it's more of a it's more of an
insurance policy in case we're not here
you know well
I don't know but there's something
I think about we as humans don't often
think about this but
it's like like whenever I um
record a video I've done this a couple
times in my life I've recorded a video
for My Future Self just for personal
just for fun and it's always just
fascinating
to think about
that preserving yourself for a future
Civilizations for me it was preserving
myself for a future me but that's a
little that's a little fun example of
archival these podcasts are are
preserving you and I in a way yeah for
future uh hopefully well after we're
gone but you don't often we're sitting
here talking about this
you are not thinking about the fact that
you and I are going to die and there
will be like 10 years after somebody
watching this and we're still alive you
know it's in some sense I do
I'm here because I want to talk about
ideas and these ideas transcend me and
they transcend this time in in on our
planet
um we're talking here about ideas that
could be around a thousand years from
now or a million years from now I when I
wrote my book
I had an audience in mind and one of the
clearest audiences was aliens no were
people reading this 100 years from now
yes I said to myself how do I make this
book relevant to somebody reading this
100 years from now what would they want
to know that we were thinking back then
what would make it like that was an
interesting it's still an interesting
book I'm not sure I can I've achieved
that but that was how I thought about it
because these ideas especially in the
third part of the book the ones we were
just talking about you know these crazy
what sounds like crazy ideas about you
know storing our knowledge and and you
know merging our brains of computers and
and sending you know our machine down
into space it's not going to happen in
my lifetime
um and they may not even happen the next
hundred years they may not happen for a
thousand years who knows uh but we have
the unique opportunity right now we you
me and other people like this
um to sort of at least propose the
agenda
um that might impact the future like
that that's the fascinating way to think
uh both like writing or creating
try to make
try to create ideas try to create things
that uh hold up in time yeah you know
understanding how the brain works we're
going to figure that at once that's it
it's gonna be figured out once and after
that that's the answer and people will
people will study that thousands of
years now we still we still you know
venerate Newton and Einstein and um and
you know because because ideas are
exciting even well into the future well
the interesting thing is like big ideas
even if they're wrong are still useful
like
yeah especially if they're not
completely wrong like
Newton's laws are not wrong they're just
Einsteins are better right so
um well it's so yeah I mean but we're
talking with Newton and Einstein we're
talking about physics I wonder if we'll
ever achieve that kind of clarity but
understanding um like complex systems
and the this particular manifestation of
complex systems which is the human brain
well I I'm totally optimistic we can do
that I mean we're making progress at it
I don't see any reasons why we can't
completely I mean completely understand
in a sense
um you know we don't really completely
understand what all the molecules in
this water bottle are doing but you know
we have laws that sort of capture it
pretty good
um and uh so we'll have that kind of
understanding I mean it's not like
you're going to have know what every
neuron in your brain is doing
um but enough to uh first of all to
build it and second of all to do you
know do what physics does which is like
have uh concrete experiments where we
can validate we're we're this is
happening right now like it's not this
is not some future thing
um you know I'm very optimistic about I
know about our work and what we're doing
we'll have to prove it to people but
um
I I consider myself a rational person
and
um you know until fairly recently I
wouldn't have said that but right now
I'm where I'm sitting right now I'm
saying yeah we can this is going to
happen there's no big obstacles to it
um we finally have a framework for
understanding what's going on in the
cortex and
um
and that's liberating it's it's like oh
it's happening so I I can't see why we
wouldn't be able to understand it I just
can't
okay oh so I mean on that topic let me
ask you to play Devil's Advocate
is it possible for you to imagine
look a hundred years from now and
looking at your book
uh in which ways might your ideas be
wrong oh I worry about this all the time
um
yeah still useful yeah
yeah
yeah
I think there's you know
um well I can I can best relate it to
like things I'm worried about right now
so we talk about this voting idea right
it's happening there's no question
that's happening but it could be far
more
[Music]
uh there's there's enough things I don't
know about it that it might be working
in ways differently than I'm thinking
about the kind of what's voting who's
voting you know where our
representations I talked about you have
a thousand models of the coffee cup like
that that could turn out to be wrong
um because it may be
maybe there are a thousand models that
are sub models but not really a single
model The Coffee Cup
um I mean there's things these are all
sort of on the edges things that I I
present is like oh it's so simple and
clean well it's not that it's always
going to be more complex and
um
and there's parts of the theory which I
don't understand the complexity well so
I think I think the idea is the brain is
a distributed modeling system it's not
controversial at all right it's not
that's well understood by many people
the question then is are each quarter of
a column an independent modeling system
right
um
I could be wrong about that
um I don't think so but I worry about it
my intuition not even thinking why you
could be wrong is the same intuition I
have about any sort of physicist
like strength Theory
that we as humans desire for a clean
explanation and a hundred years from now
uh intelligent systems might look back
at us and laugh at how we try to get rid
of the whole mess by having simple
explanation when the reality is it's
it's way Messier and in fact it's
impossible to understand you can only
build it it's like this idea of complex
systems and cellular automata you can
only launch the thing you cannot
understand it yeah I think that you know
the history of science suggests that's
not likely to occur
um The History of Science suggests that
look as a theorist and we're theorists
you look for simple explanations right
fully knowing that whatever simple
explanation you're going to come up with
is not going to be completely correct I
mean it can't be I mean it's just it's
just more complexity but that's the role
a theorists play they they sort of they
give you a framework on which you now
can talk about a problem and figure out
okay now we can start digging in more
details the best Frameworks stick around
while the details change you know again
you know the classic example is Newton
and Einstein right you know
um Newton's theories are still used
they're still valuable they're still
practical they're not like wrong just
they've been refined yeah but that's in
physics it's not obvious by the way it's
not obvious for physics either that the
Universe should be such that it's
amenable to these simple but it's so far
it appears to be as far as we can tell
um yeah I mean but as far as we could
tell and but it's also an open question
whether the brain is amenable to such
clean theories that's the uh well that's
the brain but intelligence well I I I
don't know I would take intelligence
they you know
um
well okay
the evidence we have suggests that the
human brain is is a at the one time
extremely messy and complex but there's
some parts that are very regular and
structured that's why we started the
neocortex it's extremely regular in its
structure yeah and unbelievably so and
then I mentioned earlier the other thing
is it's it's Universal abilities it is
so flexible to learn so many things we
don't we haven't figured out what it
can't learn yet we don't know but we
haven't figured out yet but if you
learned things that it never was evolved
to learn so those give us hope
um that's why I went into this field
because I said you know this regular
structure it's doing this amazing number
of things there's got to be some
underlying principles that are that are
common and other other scientists have
come up with the same conclusions
um and so that's promising it's
promising and um and that's and whether
the theories play out exactly this way
or not that is the role that theorists
play and so far it's worked out well
even though you know maybe you know we
don't understand all the laws of physics
but so far it's been pretty damn useful
the ones we have are our our theories
are pretty useful